hello everyone
i'm in bucharest romania about
two-thirds of the way through the
european leg of my
beyond order tour which seems to be
going
very nicely i've spent some time over
the last few weeks
it's june 16 2022 by the way
writing a couple of articles for the
telegraph
one of which i'm going to read to you
today
called
butchers and
liars we are sacrificing our children on
the altar of a malicious far-left
ideology
the medical profession is crumbling in
response to
radical transgender activists
there's good evidence that many ancient
societies
sacrifice children to their gods parents
in ancient phoenician colonies in
carthage
sicily sardinia and malta
slew their offspring prior to cremating
them hoping that the gods would hear
their voices
and bless them
we are rightly appalled by this
though sometimes i wonder whether we
understand child sacrifice
far
more than we'd like to admit i saw a
video the other day featuring an
american surgeon bragging
that he had performed more than 3 000
double mastectomies on young women who
had paid for gender reassignment
individuals confused
one might say encouraged
by those who profit from it into
believing that their adolescent
emotional trials can be cured and
happiness reign forever
if they subject themselves to this
brutal practice
and it is brutal
a process that often includes not only
the aforementioned mastectomies but
other appalling surgical processes
orchiectomy that's castration in blunter
language the removal of the uterus the
demolition of the musculature of the
forearm to make what is not a penis but
must be referred to as such
all of that
for someone purporting to be a physician
to perform this on children
to me at least seems like something
worthy
of a prison sentence
whatever happened to the doctrine
expressed by the ancient language as
premium non-nausea
first
do no harm
the hippocratic oath has been replaced
by a delusion a belief that can be
summarized as
by blocking the puberty of children and
then surgically altering them we are
only restoring what is theirs by right
a child's feelings are the final
arbiters of their reproductive destiny
and any attempt to contest their gender
identity
risks increasing their proclivity for
suicide
lies
lies
lies
then
butchery
changing standards
psychologists those in my own personal
field of medicine have also surrendered
to this group think the american
psychological association's task force
on guidelines for psychological practice
with transgender and gender
non-conforming people
tgnc
insist that psychologists and other
professional counselors offer trans
affirmative care starting with such
niceties as displaying tgnc affirmative
resources in waiting areas
practitioners are also asked to examine
how their language eg use of incorrect
pronouns and names may reinforce the
gender binary in overt or subtle and
unintentional ways
these guidelines first read like a
manual of indoctrination written by
marxist ideologues and second
like a document designed to undermine
and destroy
the practice of therapy itself
but at an alarming rate these guidelines
have transformed themselves into
punitive laws governing what a
psychologist or counselor may say and
think in relation to their clients
let me make myself perfectly clear
speaking as a professional whether in
america britain or anywhere it is not
the place of a therapist to affirm or
conversely to deny the identity of
anyone whom they admit into their care
people come to see a therapist often
after long and painful deliberation
because they are suffering confused or
both
the job of that therapist is to listen
to question
and to proceed with do caution
neither providing cheap advice and
thereby stealing their clients successes
or heaping failure upon them nor
assuming special knowledge of the proper
outcome for a given individual
there is simply no way i would ever tell
a 15 year old adolescent that she is
absolutely correct if sometimes she
feels more masculine than feminine
however that feeling might emerge and
that if she feels that surgery is the
answer
then recommend hormones that day
i would instead spend many weeks even
perhaps many months or years listening
to her
unwrap her story using caution
as my watchword
and help her to come to some thorough
and well-developed understanding of both
her autobiographical history
and her destiny
that is not affirmation and neither is
it denial how could i possibly dare to
do either when someone has come to me
because they are mixed up and desperate
a state of twinned experience indicating
a profound confusion about identity
itself
radical new guidelines
i am focusing on the american
psychological association apa
because it is the body charged with
establishing the norms and ideals for
clinical practice in the most populous
democracy on earth principles that will
and are
spread around the west more broadly
including in britain
some of their guidelines are appalling
enough to deserve dissection
guideline one psychologists understand
that gender is a non-binary construct
that allows for a range of gender
identities and that a person's gender
identity may not align with sex
assigned
at birth
i don't understand this radical
postmodern definition of gender
one that rests on a person's deeply felt
or inherent sense of being one sex over
another regardless of biology
psychologically it is indisputably the
case that a non-trivial proportion of
males have a feminine temperament which
essentially means that they experience
higher levels of negative emotion such
as anxiety and the analogues of pain
grief frustration disappointment
depression and are more agreeable
compassionate polite
than typical males and equally true that
a non-trivial proportion of females have
a masculine temperament but this does
not change how objectively professionals
should measure a person's
gender psychologist once cared if
measurement followed
standard practices of validity and
reliability
try reading for example a document
published by the apa itself in 2014
where you will learn that a psychologist
worthy of his salt is obliged to utilize
constructs
i.e terms such as gender in a
technically appropriate manner this
means at the very least that fundamental
attributes must be measurable
and measured properly
but all that goes out the window when
we're discussing the magic of gender now
which is entirely subjectively defined
even though that insistence indubitably
contravenes the earlier standards
but feelings uber always folks and it's
no joke particularly if you're 15 and
have undergone surgery that makes you
incapable of reproducing often to foster
someone else's sense of moral
superiority or sense of self attributed
compassion
a word that increasingly makes me
shudder when i encounter it
new doctrines psychologists are also now
adopting the simple minded and anything
but revolutionary doctrine of
intersectionality without question
and what is that doctrine nothing more
than the claim that human beings are
characterized by identities that span
multiple dimensions
any given person has a race ethnicity
sex temperament five dimensions there
alone intelligence level etc
we've known that forever
it's only became a hot
cultural item since fools noted the
obvious fact that minority status might
be additive or multiplicative i hate to
even point out given that anyone with
any sense whatsoever also knew without
any statistical training that it was
possible to be of latino extraction say
or even latin x to use that absurd
demeaning and patronizing term and
female
simultaneously
one cannot question this however without
fear of being ostracized by one's
colleagues note the chilling wording of
guideline seven
psychologists understand the need to
promote social change that reduces the
negative effects of stigma on the health
and well-being of tgnc people
in summary
if you're not an activist
and one of our activists then you better
be watching over your shoulder
so what should govern my behavior as a
therapist and your expectations as a
client
the answer to that is
whatever the activists deem a priority
at their whim
and remember that in court folks
active
malevolence
i'm increasingly ashamed to be a
clinical psychologist given the utter
cowardice spinelessness and apathy that
characterizes many colleagues and even
more so my professional associations
at least in 20 years when we all come to
regret this terrible social experiment
i may be able to say i said no
when they all came to insist that we
participate in the sacrifice of our
children
other countries and britain in
particular must not make the same
mistakes as in the us and elsewhere
i cannot consent to what we are doing
i cannot abide by what have become the
doctrines of my discipline i believe
that the acts of the
medical professional rushing to
disfigure sterilize and harm young
people with what are clearly ill-advised
dangerous and experimental procedures
cross the line from do no harm
to outright harm
only if we bury our heads in the sand
will sterility impaired or absent sexual
function complex reactions to poorly
understood hormones expense
and intermingled with all of that
misery and confusion
continue for countless young people we
must address the threat posed to the
integrity of the entire education system
as well
as indoctrination into the same
philosophy that spawned this surgical
enterprise and the apa guidelines grows
it threatens general public trust
that our peace and prosperity depends
upon
and
by the way
it will most definitely be the case that
a disproportionate number of children
freed from their hypothetical gender
confusion would have grown up to be
physically intact and fully functional
gay adults
need i point out that this unpalatable
fact makes a mockery of any claim that
the extended alphabet world of the lgbtq
plus codery in any sense constitutes a
homogeneous and unified
community
we have crossed the line from
ideological possession to active
malevolence and we are multiplying our
sin
there is an intersection for you by
attributing our appalling actions
to compassion
heaven help us
truly